hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the Grantchester where the
things are just getting better and
better and it's the second round of the
classics in England versus maxime
beaugeois grub and after yesterday's
game were doing had the black pieces he
had MVL on the ropes but
mvo was able to defend and well the
creative genius that he is he was able
to wiggle out of dings grass but now we
have a game again a classic platformer a
ding with the white pieces and we do
have a nice photo again courtesy of
Leonard Otis official photographer of
the Grantchester there we have it ding
very happy the young gentleman played d4
on the board even though ding did not
want to play d4 so then retreated the
move and then played what what's the
ding wanted to play which is c4 so we
have the English opening on the board
maxime replies with c5 with g3 g6 Bishop
to g2 Bishop to g7 so the symmetrical
variation Knight c3 Knight to c6 Knight
to f3 and here Maxine breaks symmetry
with a 5 we have castles by dink and
Knight G to e7 where and now you can
play d6 you can Castle you can play f5
if if possible d3 biding we have d6 and
now a 3 now with a5 preventing v4 from
ding and now rook the b1 preparing to
push the beep on we have castles by
Maxime and now b3 being very flexible
and now you can develop the Bishop to b2
we looked the b8 preparing b6 or b5
depending on what white plays Bishop to
b2 and h6 now and there are games in the
database were III in tonight's the even
was played but Knights the b2 is a new
move biding and I caught a glimpse of an
interview with ding after the game where
he said that night study 2 was still
inside his preparation so we have Bishop
to e6 by Maxine and now Knight to d5
Dean says if he was very happy when when
he founded this idea because he just
felt that white was better with b5 by
maksim now you cannot capture
otherwise you lose a piece here so III
and Queen to d7 connecting rooks also
Bishop to h3 as an idea in the future we
have rook to e1 by ding and now Bishop
to g4 attacking dings Queen Queen to c2
and the now comes rook F to c8 so
everything is nicely developed and now
Knight to e4 here link says that he was
very happy when he saw Knight to e4
because after Knight capture Sundy 5c
captures and Aoife and Knights the e7 he
saw that
well now the the d5 one is under attack
but that four-night the d2 his attack is
will not attack what his position is
very nice and that the knight is
actually excellently placed on d2
because the night it's coming to see for
the point is and the way Dean you
explained it the roof is nb8 it's not an
a8 so white black doesn't really have a
good way of preventing white from
pushing gave 4 and white by pushing a 4
will this way or one way or another
eliminate the b5 point and then you free
the c-4 square for your knight and
that's the point of dings idea so here
maxim went Bishop to h3 and now better
back to h1 here ding was considering
efore but he said that after characters
captures an f5 that black would have a a
solid attack you can continue with f4
and that he didn't enjoy where this was
going so he simply retreated Bishop to
h1 and now Knight to f5 by Maxine and
here finally a for now he's winning the
c-4 square for his night with h5 by
Maxine now comes 8 characters on b5 rook
captures on b5 and now you can use the C
4 square whenever you want for a knight
but first looked the a1
now the a5 pawn will be under attack the
bishop can come to c3 you can attack it
you can double rooks on the a file so it
will be very hard to hold on to the a a
5 point with h4 by maksim and now Bishop
the c3 first adding another attacker to
the a5 form look the a 8 adding another
defender and now comes Luke to a 4 here
just getting the rook into the attack a
very nice rook lift now you can just
shift it over to the King side not at
the
but when it becomes possible we have
Queen to d8 just preparing that add
another defender to the pawn here and
the now comes the Bishop to f3
so rook 8 b8 capturing here doesn't
really give you anything captures
captures and it's perfectly fine for
white so here after Bishop to three we
have rook a to b8 now putting pressure
on the b-pawn if the knight moves and
now comes Luke a back to e one rookie
back to a1 and with Bishop to h6 and
here Dean says that he thought about
grabbing the e5 pawn but he just didn't
like what Bishop captures and III gave
black he said if Bishop captures Knight
captures on e3 then black would have
sufficient compensation for for the
piece because after H captors and g3
just how the space would open up in
front of the White King so he retreated
with rook to e1 but now we have Queen to
g5 so getting more pieces into the
attack but ding just kicks it away
Knights the e4 the Queen now has to go
back Queen to d8 and now rook to a3 just
adding another defender to the b3 pawn
Knight to e7 and now Knight back to D 2
we have Knight to f5 and here Queen to
d1 Bishop back to g7 and now comes g4 I
think said that he didn't find any other
way to how to continue the game in in a
proper way without capturing the a 5
point so nice the h6 and now King to h1
after f5 is played you do want to have
your rook all ready to be put on the g1
square with f5 by black and now G
captures an f5 G captures on f5 and rook
to g1 now the rookies on a very
dangerous file so Queen to d7
preparing to bring the other Brooke into
the game and now Queen to d2
now black plays King to 8 you don't want
your Bishop to be pinned and here at
England said that he was considering
grabbing the pond but he just felt that
this rook lift was a much better idea
and it requires a lot of calculation
because here maxime played rook captures
nb3 saying okay if you capture my rock
I'm gonna capture your rook and Bing
played rook captures on h4 giving up the
c3 Bishop for the h3 bishop
so rook captures we have rook captures
in the now
maxime just started pushing his past
point he played a four but also if you
try something like rook the g8 trying to
counter it immediately then Bishop the
h5 is very strong and white will get a
very strong position very quickly
Bishop to f8 you hope the trade of the
route but Bishop to g6 and even after
Queen to g7 you're gonna go Queen to h5
and black really doesn't have any good
moves it's just a much better position
you can play Queen captures on f5 as the
knight is pinned you can get the Knight
to c4 now go after the pawn her as the
d6 pawn a lot of very strong ideas for
white
so instead Maxime just started pushing
his passport we have E for we have
looked the c2 now pinning the night rook
to h5 going after this pawn here as the
knight is pinned just pawn captures here
so f4 magazine closes the position and
now Queen to d1 re maneuvering the Queen
the rook is under attack rook beat the
b2 now adding another rook to the second
rank attacking the knight here but now
ignite the C for not allowing Knight
captures here or something like night 2
D 2 because this Knight is the b2 night
is hanging we have a three offering the
exchange but first dingos Bishop to g4 a
very very strong move improving the
position of the bishop Queen to d8 and
only now Knight captures and b2 so
grabbing the exchange with rook captures
and b2 and now Bishop to e6 grabbing the
g8 we're away from the from the black
King and here we have a 2 so here now of
course rook the rook the b1 is an idea
if if it becomes possible but feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
a winning idea for doing in this
position while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
the best the best rook lift there is
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's rook captures on g7 okay
it's a rook lift with a capture but
still but the point is if you don't play
rook to be one you do trap the Queen and
you can bring another Queen into the
game whitey just says be my guest
because the Ruby g1 and now if you win
the Queen or bring another Queen enter
game doesn't really matter it's just a
rook captures on h6 mate so this is
dings idea
so after rook captures and g7 you don't
have the option of doing something like
that
maxime captured the rook but now Queen
the g1 this is the move you have to find
King to f8 and here Dean just played
rook to f5 check and it was in this
position that Maxine Rochelle DeGraw
resigned the game so game 2 goes to ding
game 1 almost once to think but the game
2 does go to things so now ding is
leading the match by a margin of 6
points and it's not gonna be easy for
mvl yes you do get 4 points for winning
the rapid but you know it's not not
gonna be easy
well winning a game against a ding in
the rapid section I don't know I think
mvl is the second highest rated rapid
player in the world I think Magnus
overtook him now but it's still still
gonna be hard to win games against ding
so here he resigned because well if you
captured them it just made into Queen
checks and g18 d7 and Queen to f7 is
made and if you don't capture it if your
start running away with the King King 8
or 7 doesn't really matter it's pretty
much the same thing when g7 check the
King has no squares you have to block
and Queen captures on f7 will again be
made so after Luke the 5 MBL resigned
and ding takes the lead and in the
classical time time section which is
really which is really awesome for him
since he is above 2800 so a win against
MVL brings him even higher above 2800
which is you know always always great
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed we will check out the game
between
Magnus and Levin but that was still
being played when I started recording
this video so we'll see what's happening
there it's also really a crazy game so
we're definitely gonna check it out I
would like to thank Adam Decker and
Cimarron for safer although Ali jr.
Randy raveling and Paul Gauguin for a
contributor to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video Sierra
thank you for watching and I will see
soon continuing the coverage of the
Grantchester finals checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and starting our
next big saga fairly soon and also do be
a do be a part of the subscribers video
2020 you will find all the important
information in the description below the
first thing you will see so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Saturday